hasta hoy todas las reacciones que hemos
visto han sido de la forma a minúscula
ok a minúscula moles de la molécula a
mayúscula ok
+ b minúscula moles de la molécula de
estas dos moléculas van a reaccionar y
formar a los siguientes productos y no
ser digamos que tenemos dos productos
podríamos haber tenido tantos productos
como quisiéramos pero para hacer las
cosas más fáciles vamos a decir que
tenemos dos productos
el producto se moles de la molécula se
ok más de moles de minúscula de la
molécula de d mayúscula ok y la idea
aquí es que fueron en una dirección van
de aquí para acá si hacemos un pequeño
diagrama de energía como lo hicimos en
el vídeo pasado esto se vería más o
menos así yo puedo tener aquí mi
diagraman ok y justo
aquí vamos a medir la reacción o como la
reacción progresa ok como la reacción
progresa y fue justo lo que vimos en el
vídeo
de cinética podrías imaginar que aquí
tienes un estado de energía mayor
justo este de aquí que de hecho aquí
tendrías a moles de la molécula a ok más
bemoles de la molécula ve ok
aquí tienes estas dos moléculas y si a
esto le agregamos una cierta energía de
activación bueno pues se va a ver así
hasta llegar a un nivel de energía menor
que es justo este que tengo aquí donde
es más estable y es justo aquí donde
tenemos ce moles de la molécula se más
de moles de la molécula de y por cierto
es importante mencionar que sólo se da
si tienes suficiente energía de
activación ahora esto sólo va en esta
dirección
una vez aquí es muy difícil volver para
camps es decir que si tiene suficientes
moléculas de ibm obtendrás fácilmente
moléculas de state y la reacción sólo va
en esta dirección pero no es así como
sucede siempre en la realidad
en realidad bueno algunas veces sucede
pero también puede decir en la otra
dirección
es decir en muchos casos la reacción
puede ir en ambas direcciones así que
podríamos escribir en lugar de esta
reacción que va en una sola dirección
podríamos escribir una reacción de dos
direcciones como esta que voy a poner
justo aquí y recuerda que solo para no
confundir demasiado estos de aquí son
los números de moles o las proporciones
de las moléculas que tenemos y es que
esto va a ser muy relevante en unos
segundos porque entonces si nosotros
pensamos en la siguiente reacción tengo
a moles de la molécula a más de moldes
de la molécula
ok y esto nos va a dar c moles de la
molécula c + d moles de la molécula de
pero decimos que va en ambas direcciones
es decir vamos dando en esta dirección
como en la dirección contraria y para
hacer esto nosotros podemos decir que
esto nos va a llevar a una reacción en
equilibrio si hacemos estas flechas en
ambas direcciones
eso significa que algunas de éstas
para formar estas otras pero al mismo
tiempo algunas de estas otras van a
formar un poco de estas moléculas y en
algún punto voy a alcanzar el equilibrio
cuando la velocidad de reacción de las
moléculas es igual a la velocidad de
reacción de las otras moléculas las que
van en la otra dirección en la dirección
contraria entonces voy a decir que estoy
alcanzando un equilibrio
equilibrio que lee frío ok justo eso es
lo que significa que tengamos una
reacción en equilibrio ahora seguramente
te estás preguntando por qué sucedería
esto en lugar de esto y puedo pensar en
una situación si dibujamos ahora un
nuevo diagrama de energía déjenme
cambiar a este color y vamos a hacer
aquí nuestro nuevo diagrama de energía
podría ocurrir más o menos lo siguiente
aquí tengo a mi diagrama
déjenme dibujar que estos dos son mis
ejes y bueno pues de ocurrir entonces
que ambos estados tienen energías
similares o no tan diferentes
ojo podrían existir otras razones pero
esta es la primera que se me viene a la
mente nosotros podemos tener aquí el
estado de energía ok de a más ven y
entonces después necesitamos algo de
energía de activación voy a poner aquí
algo de energía de activación y tal vez
la energía con la que acabemos es decir
se más de sea una energía a más o menos
por aquí un poco menor que la potencial
pero no mucho menos aquí tenemos
ok es esta parte de aquí y aquí tenemos
se más de ok y justo como tenemos casi
los mismos estados de energía entonces
es igual de probable o tal vez haya más
moléculas que vayan en esta dirección
pero existen algunas moléculas que van a
ir alguna reacción que va a ir en esta
otra dirección
la mayor parte pueda ir en esta
dirección pero algunos de ellos pueden
ir en esta otra dirección si algunas de
estas moléculas tienen la cantidad
correcta de energía cinética ok de estas
moléculas entonces podrían ir en la
dirección contraria ya que van a superar
esta energía de activación e ir hacia
atrás y ojo el estudio de esto se llama
equilibrio estás viendo las
concentraciones de diferentes moléculas
y bueno si nosotros lo queríamos
comparar con la cinética la cinética nos
decía qué tan rápido va a pasar justo
esto es decir qué puedo hacer para
cambiar la energía de activación esta
joroba que tengo aquí esta joroba el
equilibrio estudia cuáles serían las
concentraciones
moléculas que harán que la velocidad en
esta dirección sea igual que la
velocidad en esta otra dirección y
quiero ser muy claro con esto cuando
hablo de equilibrio quiero decir que la
velocidad que va en esta dirección es
decir estamos pensando en la reacción
directa tiene la misma velocidad es
igual que la velocidad que va en la
dirección contraria es decir en la
reacción inversa o en la reacción
contraria y ojo esto no quiere decir que
las concentraciones de las dos son
iguales podrías terminar no sé con un
25% de concentración de estas dos
soluciones un 25 por ciento de la
concentración para las soluciones
eventuales de aire y 75% justo aquí todo
lo que sabemos es que en algún punto has
alcanzado el equilibrio porque el
equilibrio simplemente significa que
estas concentraciones no van a cambiar
nunca más y bueno para esto déjenme
darte un ejemplo si nosotros pensamos
y se me ocurre hablar del proceso de
saber si nosotros nos tomamos
hidrógeno ok en forma gaseosa voy a
tener al gas nitrógeno ya esto le sumó
tres veces a hidrógeno también en forma
gaseosa el gas hidrógeno y esto nos da
ok y ojo esta es una reacción en
equilibrio por lo tanto va hacia ambas
direcciones y esto nos da dos moles de
amoniaco dos moles de amoniaco ok a esto
se le conoce como el proceso de javier y
es justo el que vamos a hablar en el
siguiente vídeo o espera estoy olvidando
que este también es un gas y bueno en
este caso podemos decir que si nos
fijamos justo en esta reacción que
tenemos aquí entonces am y déjame
cambiar de color puedo decir que aquí el
valor de a de minúscula es la cantidad
de moles que vamos a tomar de la
molécula de hidrógeno que en este caso
es 1 ok a minúsculas 1 mientras que a
mayúscula es este elemento el nitrógeno
la molécula de nitrógeno ya esto le
vamos a agregar y deja
ponerlo con otro color se me ocurre
decir que p b en este caso toma el valor
de 3 ok
mientras que en mayúscula estos de
minúscula d mayúscula está hablando de
la molécula de hidrógeno
ok y esto es una ecuación que está en
equilibrio con am y aquí tengo c
minúscula en este caso se minúscula
sería la cantidad de moles que tomamos
de amoniaco que es 2 en este caso vale 3
que es la cantidad de moles que tomamos
de hidrógeno que es 3 ok se minúscula es
2 mientras que s mayúscula es ni más
menos que la molécula de amoniaco y ojo
solo quiero que te des cuenta que esto
es una manera abstracta de escribir todo
este tipo de ecuaciones ahora lo que es
interesante en las reacciones de
equilibrio es que puedes definir una
constante y para eso déjeme bajar un
poco la pantalla vamos a definir una
constante que se le conoce como la
constante de equilibrio y para eso
utilizamos otro color nuevo la constante
equilibrium y esta constante de
equilibrio se define como tomar los
productos o el lado derecho en este caso
pero bueno por convención vamos a decir
que vamos a tomar primero a la dirección
directa que va de hamás ven
ok y nos va a darse más de y entonces
así que te tomas la concentración de
cada uno de los productos en este caso
ese ítem ok los multiplicas el uno al
otro
déjame ponerlo así nos vamos a tomar la
concentración de ese que por la
concentración de de y vamos a ponerlo
con este color a esto lo voy a
multiplicar por la concentración de de
ok y los eleva a la relación molar que
te estás tomando en este caso es de
minúscula y en este caso es ce minúscula
es decir la concentración de se ha
elevado a la ce a la c minúscula y la
concentración desde grande elevado a la
d minúscula y cuando digo concentración
ellos usualmente y bueno específicamente
cuando nosotros vemos o hablamos de un
curso de introducción a la química la
concepto
en polaridad esto se está midiendo en la
edad que en general podemos decir que la
polaridad está dada en moles moles por
litro por litro y bueno hace un par de
vídeos cuando te enseñe lo que era
modalidad dije tú sabes moles por litro
pero realmente no me gusta mucho esto
porque el volumen de tu fluido o tu gas
va a depender de la temperatura así que
no me gusta muchos a esta palabra
modularidad pero en este caso está bien
porque está constante equilibrio también
es cierta sólo para una temperatura dada
sólo para una temperatura dada entonces
si nosotros nos fijamos en las
concentraciones de estos productos de
los exponentes y vamos a terminar de
definir esta constante de equilibrio y
bueno tal vez con más calma hablaré de
todo esto en el próximo vídeo esta
constante equilibrio va a ser igual a la
concentración de s&m elevado a la se
minúscula que es la relación molar por
la concentración de de elevado a la d
minúscula que su concentración
y tomamos los productos ya esto lo voy a
dividir ok vamos a ponerlo con este
color a esto lo voy a dividir por las
concentraciones de los reactivos o de lo
que está pasando en el lado izquierdo de
esta ecuación así que lo voy a dividir
am aquí tengo con este color entre la
concentración de a ok elevado a su
relación molar ok
multiplicado a su vez por la
concentración debe ok justo lo voy a
poner así por la concentración debe
elevado a su vez a la potencia de
minúscula y bueno es que lo interesante
sobre todo esto y esto es un poco de
simplificación porque no aplica para
todas las reacciones pero la mayoría de
las cosas que vas a encontrar en tu
curso de introducción a las clases de
química esto es verdad y una vez que
establezcas esta constante de equilibrio
te va a servir para una cierta
temperatura ojo esto es cierto sólo para
una cierta temperatura entonces puedes
cambiar las concentraciones y con esto
vas a poder ser capaz de predecir cuáles
van a ser las concentraciones
resultantes
déjenme darte un ejemplo déjame tomar
esta reacción del proceso deja ver y si
quisiéramos calcular su constante de
equilibrio y para eso déjeme bajar otro
poco en la pantalla ok qué tal si
calculamos la constante de equilibrio de
este proceso deja ver entonces que me
quedaría la constante de equilibrio de
este proceso deja ver va a ser igual y
ahora necesitamos verla para una cierta
temperatura así que voy a tomarme la a
25 grados celsius que es aproximadamente
la temperatura ambiente así que lo que
haría es que nos tomaríamos los
productos que en este caso el único
producto es el amoniaco por lo tanto me
voy a tomar la concentración del
amoniaco ok la concentración de nh3 ok
esto elevado al número de moles que se
producen por cada molde nitrógeno más
tres moles de hidrógeno que es 2 es
decir esto elevado a la segunda potencia
y todo esto lo vamos a dividir entre y
ahora me voy a fijar en esta parte de
aquí lo voy a dividir entre la
concentración de los reactivos que en
este caso es nitrógeno ok nitrógeno
elevado
bueno a la primera potencia porque por
cada molde nitrógeno más tres moles de
hidrógeno obtenemos dos de amoniaco
entonces lo voy a dejar así ya esto lo
voy a multiplicar por la concentración
de mi otro reactivo que es el hidrógeno
ok por la concentración de hidrógeno
esto elevado a la tercera potencia que
es la cantidad de moles que necesitamos
para producir dos moles de amoniaco y
bueno solamente recuerda que pongo esto
en corchetes porque estoy figurando la
concentración la concentración así que
tendríamos que averiguar el mol por
litro oa veces dicen la polaridad de
cada una de estas cosas y esto me dará
alguna constante ahora bien si en cambio
de esto podemos ser un ejercicio donde
podemos resolver y calcular el resto
entonces qué te parece si nos movemos un
poco voy a mover un poco esta pantalla
para hacer el siguiente ejercicio
bien pues digamos que tengo en la
reacción
un modo de la molécula lo voy a poner
así a más ya esto le voy a agregar a se
me ocurre poner dos moldes de la
molécula ve dos goles de la molécula ve
esto está en equilibrio
esto está en equilibrio con adam y me
voy a tomar tres veces la molécula ok se
de lujo y vamos a decir que una vez que
está en equilibrio vamos y medimos las
concentraciones y obtenemos que la
concentración a meterme a ponerlo con
este color la concentración de esta
molécula am es lo mismo que 1 molar 1
molar ok que es exactamente lo mismo que
por litro por litro ok y después en este
mismo equilibrio nos damos cuenta que la
concentración debe esto es lo mismo que
3 molar ok lo cual es lo mismo que tres
moles o que moles por litro litro ok y
en el caso de si nos damos cuenta que su
concentración la concentración de cm es
exactamente lo mismo que y se me ocurre
para no hacerlo muy grande en una molar
1 molar lo cual es lo mismo que un
entre litro ok y si ahora queremos
calcular esta constante
de equilibrio que vamos a obtener que en
mi constante de equilibrio mi constante
de equilibrio va a ser exactamente igual
a y entonces lo voy a poner con este
color va a ser igual a la concentración
de ese ok esto elevado a la cantidad de
moles que tenemos de la molécula se lo
cual es 3 ok esto elevado a la tercera
potencia y esto a su vez está dividido
entre la concentración de esta molécula
am ok vamos a ponerlo así la
concentración de esta molécula ha
elevado a la cantidad de moles que
tenemos de esta molécula que es 1 ok ya
esto lo voy a multiplicar por la
concentración de b elevado a la segunda
potencia elevado a la segunda potencia
pero esto lo podemos calcular esto es
exactamente lo mismo
ok déjame ponerlo así que y bueno la
concentración de ese es 1 molar entonces
me va a quedar
elevado a la tercera potencia esto a su
vez dividido entre am ok la
concentración de a es 1 molar 1 por am
la concentración debe elevado al
cuadrado que es 3 elevado al cuadrado ok
y esto es exactamente lo mismo que y
bueno si leas las cuentas te va a quedar
1 entre a 91 bueno ok
un noveno es esta constante de
equilibrio y bueno esto nos da un par de
cosas con las cuales podemos pensar el
hecho de que esto sea menor que 1 aunque
significa
bueno pues si te das cuenta lo que está
diciendo es que tenemos una mayor
cantidad y déjame ponerlo con este color
voy a tener una mayor cantidad de
reactivos ok que lo que tengo de
nuestros productos eso quiere decir que
una vez que la reacción vaya hacia el
equilibrio todavía nos va a quedar mucho
más de esto ok que de esto o dicho de
otra manera que esta constante
equilibrio sea menor que 1 lo que está
diciendo es que esta reacción favorece
realmente a esta dirección
más a esta dirección porque va a quedar
siempre más de la cantidad de reactivos
que de la cantidad de productos favorece
a este lado izquierdo de esta reacción
es decir favorece a la dirección hacia
atrás bien piensa un poco sobre esto
ahora por otra parte si nosotros
encontramos que esta constante de
equilibrio esta constante de equilibrio
es más grande que uno bueno pues eso es
lo que está diciendo es que esto que
tenemos acá arriba es más grande que
esto que tenemos acá abajo o dicho otra
manera el numerador es más grande que el
denominador lo que implica que tenemos
mayor concentración de los productos una
vez que estamos en equilibrio que la
cantidad de concentración que tenemos de
los reactivos lo que quiere decir que
esto va a beneficiar a la parte derecha
de esta ecuación o dicho de otra manera
va a beneficiar a la reacción hacia
adelante vamos a terminar con mucho más
cosas de la derecha que con las cosas
que vamos a tener en el lado izquierdo y
bueno otra cosa interesante que podrías
averiguar es qué es lo que pasa cuando
nosotros
de otro modo a esta molécula a si
nosotros agregamos otro modo le deja a
esta reacción que es lo que va a pasar
pero bueno me acabo de dar cuenta que
queda muy poco tiempo de este vídeo y
por lo tanto yo creo que eso es lo que
vamos a ver en el siguiente vídeo por
esta parte espero que tengas un buen
sentido de que es la constante de
equilibrio de qué trata y cómo es medido
o cómo se define y en el siguiente vídeo
vamos a hablar un poco sobre si existe
otra forma en la que podamos hablar de
esta constante de equilibrio o dicho de
otra manera porque está definida justo
así esta constante de equilibrio y bueno
otra cosa que quiero que te quedás en
este vídeo es que te des cuenta que es
lo que está pasando cuando esta
constante equilibrio es menor que 1 es
decir favorecemos a la reacción hacia
atrás y qué es lo que pasa cuando este
constante es mayor que 1 es decir
favorecemos a la reacción hacia adelante
y bueno en el siguiente vídeo quiero
tocar con mucho más calma porque está
definida así esta constante equilibrio
porque tal vez podrías pensar bueno
porque no está definida de la siguiente
manera nuestra constante de equilibrio
podemos decir que estos
tres veces ok aunque es justo esto que
tenemos aquí
dividido entre a la concentración de a
más dos veces la concentración debe
justo esta idea me parece un poco más
intuitiva que esta idea para empezar
pero lo que quiero que veamos en el
próximo vídeo que esta es la idea
correcta esta es la idea correcta
mientras que esta otra idea que tenemos
aquí no es la adecuada así que tal vez
de esto vamos a hablar en el próximo
vídeo y ver por qué esto es verdad y no
necesariamente esto